one small line in Avengers infinity war
could hold the key to understanding that
shocking ending and it's also a cool
callback to 2016 s standalone Doctor
Strange flick warning major infinity war
spoilers ahead Doctor Strange has
claimed that he sees only one of 14
million 605 possible future scenarios in
which the Avengers defeat Thanos could
help to explain some of his well strange
behavior in the movie second half
infinity war features the MCU s most
powerful heroes fighting to stop Thanos
from attaining five Infinity stones and
wiping out half the life in the universe
however their plan is thrown for a loop
when Doctor Strange gives Thanos the
time stone in exchange for him sparing
Tony Stark's life the move appears to
have been a fatal one for Strange who is
wiped out after Thanos gets the mine
stone and carries out his flock but
before he turns to dust strange tells
stark that there was no other way which
suggests that giving up the stone is
critical to the Avengers victory this
could mean a few things it could suggest
that Stark will have a key part to play
in defeating Thanos and had to be spared
it could also mean that Thanos wiping
out half the life in the universe
temporarily is actually part of
Strange's winning scenario which brings
us to that subtle callback in the
characters standalone film strangest
mentor the ancient one tells him she can
never see past her own demise
I spent so many years peering through
time looking at this exact moment but I
can't see past it she then adds I
prevented countless terrible futures and
after each one there's always another
and they all lead here
never further so if Doctor Strange is
able to see beyond the moment when he is
apparently dusted by Thanos it means he
didn't really expire at vanos his
handiwork won't last in the scenario in
which the Avengers win this supports the
theory that the Avengers are just stuck
in the soul world a dimension inside the
soul stone where dead characters
sometimes go in the comics and can be
brought back to life for Avengers 4
it'll be a while before we know for sure
what's up with the docks and agnatic
words with Avengers 4 not slated to hit
theaters until May 3rd 2019 but for now
he's definitely given Marvel fans
something strange and hopeful to think
about
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]